foreign
I think there's no no question that we
need energy we are sitting here
surrounded by we wouldn't be here you
wouldn't be talking to us without energy
so we really do need to get to Solutions
is it possible to have a a clean energy
Supply and and if so what is it if not
what do we do
so we have built an entire way of life
built on finite substances and this is
the problem that no one wants to face
politicians cannot get elected if they
say this out loud and I think the public
at large is just sort of deer in the
headlights Frozen in horror because we
see the world going down around us and
we don't know what to do
so I the first the first thing we have
to do is the proper diagnosis and
building a way of life on something
that's going to run out
this was inevitable
and it was a one-time blowout industrial
civilization and in the words of Richard
heinberg the party's over there were
maybe three generations of people who
were ever going to get to experience
this level of consumption and it's it's
done it's over you know we're on the
downside of that Peak and it doesn't
really matter whether it's 10 years or
20 years like at some point there will
be there won't be enough of it left that
it's worth to get it out it's going to
take more energy to pump it out than
you'll get from the stuff you that is
pumped out so at that point it's over
and the end was built into the beginning
this is what happens when you build a
way of life on something that's not
going to last sure but you know someone
famously said what the Stone Age didn't
end because we ran out of stones I mean
you know things move on and and that's
where we're trying to get to we're
trying to get to the other you know the
next the next iteration
well the problem with all of the
so-called you know clean energy is that
they're not clean they all rest on that
same industrial platform you can't
create them without the same mining you
can't create them without vast amounts
of diesel fuel
um it they're not actually Alternatives
and this is why Ozzie zener talks about
fossil fuel and alternative water fuel
who wants to come in here okay Mike so
Leanne's right the in one sense the
party's over in the sense of the kind of
wild consumption that we've been doing
is going to trash the planet but in
another sense the party's not over and
it's not as though we suddenly have to
get used to a less fulfilling lives in
fact if we're smart about it uh there's
plenty of opportunity if we were really
smart about it we could live better than
ever before I mean don't get me wrong
the trajectory we're on at the moment is
heading for a very nasty crash really
nasty and it because there's lots of
things we don't understand about the the
exact way the science works on this it's
even quite possible that we've already
across some thresholds that are going to
take us to a very nasty place like it or
not even if we take very strong action
right now but it looks likely that if we
reframe the debate a lot and really wake
up insist on much better uh
much better stuff from our politicians
around honesty and honesty and
compassion at the global level and then
everything else will start falling out
of the Hat reduce our energy demand
absolutely you talk about developing
countries have some ins you know there
are countries that have a legitimate
case for a greater energy
Supply however it's not as though they
you know it's not as though to have good
lives they have to follow our trajectory
and and suddenly get themselves up to
the energy levels that we're on you know
a lot of the energy that we burn through
at the moment is not optimized for human
well-being at all they can actually do
better than the pathway that we've been
on and globally as a whole with all the
efficiency improvements in every field
you can think of if we could only bag
the savings from those efficiency
improvements the scope for Humanity to
reduce its energy demand is absolutely
enormous the problem is that unless we
the way that I've written about this at
length but the way that the Dynamics of
growth go is that unless you do
something to constrain the resource use
the more efficiency you put into the
system actually the more resources not
less you end up using and that's why no
it doesn't matter how uncomfortable this
is we need to come to an arrangement
that leaves the fossil fuel in the
ground and that is separate from
anything we do to grow the Renewables
it's separate from anything we do about
efficiency gain we have to constrain the
resource use in the first place it's not
just fossil fuel it's all the other it's
all the other things we extract as well
well I think I think the risk of that
frankly is that you end up with a very
unpredictable and nasty Global recession
and I fear that's actually what we're
going to see towards the end of this
year and next year precisely because
you're taking such a large bite out of
people's disposable income and because
that means they're going to curtail
their consumption and consumption
maybe something that's at the margin for
everybody in this tent but actually
consumption for somebody who's on low
incomes and uh Brazil or uh in India or
China is a matter of life or death so
these are real real uh difficult issues
I'd like to come back on something that
Leanne's saying as well because I'm
trying to get to what the vision of a
future is here if we simply say okay
we're going to be as green as possible
and reject industrial Solutions and it
seems to me that we've sold that pass
it's not by accident that people now
call this the anthropocene the the man
age in terms of uh the the ages of the
Earth because we are now such a dominant
species and we've had so much impact on
the planet already just to give you a a
one figure I promise not to give too
many but a few years before I was born
in 1950 50.
the population of this planet was two
and a half billion people the population
of this planet is now eight billion
people and the reason we're actually
able to have fewer proportionately of
those people in Starvation is because
we've had a massive increase in
synthetic fertilizer applied to
agriculture so the Green Revolution
enormous increases now but the first
thing
that the Chinese asked for when they did
the famous deal with Nixon and the
opening to China was they placed an
order for 13 ammonia plants from the
state of the art producer of those
plants Kellogg's in Texas
because they had recently within living
memory been through a famine and they
never wanted to go through that again so
you know I want to try and understand
this deep Green Vision which says we can
actually go back to some world where we
don't use a synthetic fertilizer because
actually I've seen calculations that
suggest that that 8 billion population
would have to come down to four billion
no in order to be sustainable now I've
you know maybe there may be other
calculations that show less but the the
reality is it's going to be a smaller
population so is it you
or is it you and which politician is
going to have the effectively uh the
courage to turn around and say sorry
we're going to be operating a one-child
policy in future or even a no child
policy
I'm going to abuse my position here and
say that that famine in 1961 was not
caused by a lack of fertilizer it was
caused by Mao Zedong Following lysenko
Season grain lots of reasons but not
that Mike yeah no it's not right that we
can't feed
um even the even nine or ten billion
people uh quite happily without I'm not
saying no fertilizer but drastically
reducing our fertilizers use we can be
more efficient in the way that we use it
by a lot and I think you your answer
that we can also you know the most
important thing uh you know a simple
thing in in one sense simple thing we
can do is Reduce by a long way the
amount of meat and dairy in our diets
and the pressure that that will take off
the food and land system not just uh not
just from a climate perspective but from
a feed the world perspective and from a
biodiversity perspective as well will be
enormous we can do stuff around wasting
food less and we can do a lot of stuff
around uh really sort of care careful
and highly skilled and not fully
scientifically understood yet but
emerging practices that enable a lot
more productivity out of land with a lot
less input and actually that requires a
lot more people to work on that land
um we we run our agricultural system in
a way that minimizes the people working
on it because that makes it more more
profitable per person at the moment but
actually you know Humanity has got
people coming out of its ears at the
moment and one of the most fundamentally
rewarding ways you could spend your time
is actually to work on that land so we
need more people working the land not
lesser there are all sorts of you know
it's a very complex area but there are
you know a complete revolution of how we
do the food and land system is
absolutely part of this well I want to
pick up on that to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit iai.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV